I'm here to talk about the future and
not some remote faraway future but just
next year februari 2016 so as you had
just heard the ftth council has decided
to hold the 2016 conference in
Luxembourg I in my capacity of chief
executive of the Luxembourg exhibition
in Congress Center I want to thank you
for that very wise choice I believe now
there's many clichés about luxemburgo
and I want to seize this opportunity to
rectify a few of them and give you the
facts so first question where is
Luxembourg and what the heck is
luxembourg luxembourg is a very small
country but it's a sovereign and
independent country founding member of
the european union it is nested between
Germany France and Belgium and above all
it's a nearby destination with very easy
access it's linked to the rest of Europe
by a first-class road network very good
air and rail connections making it
easily accessible from anywhere in
Europe room the population of our
country is about 500,000 the capital
luxembourg city has 100,000 inhabitants
and out of these some forty five percent
are holding a foreign passport spoken
languages are french german and english
and of course our mother tongue
luxembourgish too now there may be all
around the world there may be many
republics kingdoms emirates empires in
so on but there's only one Grand Duchy
and that's Luxembourg the only Grand
Duchy in the world we have a
constitutional monarchy we have a
parliamentary democracy the country is
headed by Grand Duke Henri and his wife
is grand duchess maria theresa so
luxembourg history goes way back into
the past more than 1,000 years actually
and it has lots of natural beauties
of them are mere minutes away from the
city center and whenever you get to
Luxembourg next year I just invite you
to discover all these beauties the old
city of Luxembourg arm has been declared
a unesco world heritage and it gives you
stunning views of the old city
fortifications and the LZ River River
and the valley now let me make a short
aggression you probably all know about
the Schengen area Schengen area is an
area that encompasses 26 European
countries that have abolished passport
control and introduced the common visa
policy now what you may not know and
that's what it has got to do with
Luxembourg is that the schengen
agreement was signed in a little village
called Schengen Schengen is a small
village at the river mozella very close
to the German in the French border and
it was signed that agreement was signed
in 1985 so as something that most people
don't know if we're Schengen comes from
although it's known all over the world
now a few things about unexpected things
about Luxembourg on the population is
really a vibrant international community
with more than 150 nationalities all
there were very small country lots of
Nash nationalities are forming a quite
interesting melting pot there Luxembourg
is of course known for its high banking
and financial expertise but not only
there's a number of international
players based in Luxembourg among which
I would just quote a few rtl group
Europe's biggest media group is in
Luxembourg a solo matala worldwide
number one in steel manufacturing is in
Luxembourg Astra worldwide number one
satellite operator is in Luxembourg so
we don't have banks only there's much
more to it too it also harbors the
headquarters of the numbers of
international institutions I would just
name the International
sorry the European Court of Justice and
the European Investment Bank you and
thanks to luxembourg's dedicated
innovation policy among which fiber
optics play a crucial role the country
is one of the best and most connected in
the world there should be something of
interest to you I believe them so it's a
lively in a very safe place to where
people usually find a very good balance
between professional and private life
lots of good food we used to say that we
have refined French cuisine with German
portions good wine and good beer bars
entertainment very active cultural scene
a lot of classical concerts but also
jazz rock music blues etc lots of
theaters stunning natural beauties all
within easy reach from the city of
Luxembourg now to illustrate all that
I've prepared a short video just two
minutes and I think that will give you
maybe another view of my country
bye
well the 2016 edition of the ftth
conference will be held at luxe expo
that's the National Exhibition in
Congress Center lacks Expo is located in
the heart of the business district very
close to shops and hotels we have seven
large holds much more space than needed
to accommodate a conference like FTTH
and we're very looking forward to have
you with us next year of course now I've
also come here to also to convey a
message from the luxembourg government
the secretary of state of the economy
with this fussing klausener has written
to the ftth council a letter which i
would like to read a few lines not the
whole letter just to say that the
luxembourg government feels deeply
honored by the decision to choose
luxembourg and will ensure that the
upcoming conference takes place under
the best conditions we are convinced we
the luxembourg government are convinced
that luxembourg is the ideal location to
host the ftth conference in 2016 and
we're pleased to let you know that the
luxembourg government will grant its
patronage to the ftth conference so
together with the luxembourg government
the whole lux x pro team is deeply
honored by the ftth council decision and
we look forward to welcoming you in
luxembourg next year in the meantime I
wish you an excellent and very
successful and fruitful conference here
in Warsaw thank you very much
you